-We are so luck to have
our friend, Fred Armisen,
leading the band all the week.
It's great to see you, Fred.
-Hi.
-It's so fun to have you here,
because you can always keep me
up to date
on your other projects.
But this one, I had to see,
because you've sort of been
doing a bit of a press tour.
I saw you on
"Good Morning America",
I saw you on NBC's very own
"Today Show",
announcing that you have
a competing holiday
with Valentine's Day
that you're starting this year.
-That's right.
[ Laughter ]
-We would love -- I think we
would all love to hear about it.
-It's called Acquaintance Day.
-Okay.
-So we're just celebrating
people that you know
kind of well, you know, you see
them once in a while
every couple of years.
-Okay.
-And those are really important
relationships --
you know, people you don't know
their last names,
but you just recognize
their face.
And it's just a celebration,
so, you know,
we're just trying to find a way
for people to send cards --
find their address first
then send the card.
-Right, I would imagine finding
an address is difficult
if you don't know
a person's last name.
-It's difficult, but at the same
time, that's the fun of it.
You know, it's that exploration
of, like, trying to find
that person -- "Oh, there you
are, you know.
Let's celebrate
Acquaintance Day."
-And now what -- wait.
So, example, if Hallmark made
an Acquaintance Day card
and I open it up,
what would it say inside,
like, what's the sort of
the text on those?
-"Remember the time we saw
each other?
Those times are always great.
The times that we saw
each other's faces
we'll always, always remember.
You're special to me
once every two years.
Thinking of you
this whole week."
It's that kind of thing.
-That's really good.
I'm so excited --
Acquaintance Day.
Look out, Valentine's Day,
a-look out.